hey
welcome back
over the past year i have had the
privilege of spending it with these two
buds and it's been
interesting not because they're the new
gaming consoles the helm the next
generation but because they're 100
digital they don't have a disc
this drive
can't
no can't do the physical game thing
marching into this new generation i made
a very conscious choice to go digital
with the xbox series s and the ps5
digital edition i know you're thinking
no trade-ins no lending or borrowing
games what if your favorite series just
banishes off the digital marketplace and
you're right you're completely justified
for feeling that way but now that i've
actually walked a year in these digital
shoes i can account for a journey that's
been well
rather
unexpected
[Music]
so why go all digital
[Music]
over the past few years i've made a
deliberate choice to own a little less
i've moved around a couple times lived
in studio apartments and in the process
not only did i have to part ways with a
lot of stuff but i haven't actually
missed it especially
the cases that is with the exception of
a few games of course
now naturally out of necessity of my
living condition
my habits shifted to an all digital
future by the tail end of the ps4
generation i had completely gone digital
so when this new generation rolled in
with digital only options
well i saw this as an opportunity for me
to just go
all in
when it comes to the two consoles and
which one enables a lifestyle better
there's no contest xbox has put its
pillars for a digital future with game
pass and cloud gaming it's the console i
turn on every single day and quick
resume a feature i didn't foresee
meaning anything to me at first has put
me in awe after booting up skyrim
several weeks after not playing it or
whenever i pop katamari to mossy back on
to roll the stress away
the feature is sort of like magic and
something one can't be done with
physical games and two something not
available on the ps5
[Music]
the other big thing that xbox has
spoiled me with is
yeah game pass
didn't see that one coming no but really
it's not just the fact that it has a
massive library it's the ability to
taste and sample so many different
things with a low commitment
this is where
strangely i kind of regret getting the
ps5 digital
as of this moment the ps5 has only
tickled toes with the ability to try new
games before buying them trial versions
are available but specifically only for
death stranding and sac boys adventure
and the feature is only available
in the uk so uh way to go brits really
got one in there when faced with a game
like returnal a game that i'm interested
in but i'm not entirely sure i want to
drop 70 on this is one of those
scenarios that would have been perfect
if a friend had owned a copy and i'd be
like yo let me borrow it let me try it
before i buy it but that simply isn't
the case so
i haven't actually played it
at all
in a way xbox has kind of warped my
purchasing habits in that regard on the
flip side of this is a game like forza
horizon 5 a game i would have never gone
out of my way to buy or play
but because it was on game pass i am now
trying it and to my surprise think it's
absolutely incredible something i would
have never known otherwise unless i was
able to just ease in and give it a shot
[Applause]
it's worth mentioning that the series s
is the inferior of the two consoles both
on a hardware and storage level but its
price made it a compelling entry point
especially for someone like me who is
not versed in the xbox ecosystem because
initially i was planning on the ps5
being my primary console with the series
s for everything else but in actuality
here we are a year later and the series
s is the one i turn on every single day
simply put the series s has amplified my
digital gaming lifestyle and though not
as powerful i've ended up buying more
games on it as it's the console i know i
turn on more frequently for the time
being the ps5 has been my demon souls
and death loop machine
but and this is a big but as this is all
according to my personal experience as a
contemporary gamer playing
mostly new games so this next section is
where we get into the
not so exciting parts of our digital
future
recently there's been a bit of a ruffle
in the digital marketplace for some
games and for some of you
it'd be enough for you to think twice
before marching off into this daring or
maybe naive
all digital future i've chosen first
there's jump force the anime crossover
fighting game publisher bandai namco is
pulling the game from digital
storefronts in february 2020
that's my cat
she's um she thought now would be a good
time to announce her presence
publisher bandai namco is pulling the
game from digital storefronts in
february 2022 with its internet lobby
shutting down later that year in august
yes its offline content will still be
playable and those who purchased it
digitally will still have it despite
lobbies being shut down online pvp
battles will still work just not ranked
ones there she is
second is metal gear solid two and three
konami are temporarily removing the
games from digital storefronts so the
publisher can renew the license for
select historical archive footage used
in each game if you own them and have
them downloaded you're good that is
unless you want to re-download them then
you won't be able to until they're put
back on the digital storefront but
according to konami this is supposedly
only temporary do you see a bird
are you distracting me
yes
okay
lastly is grand theft auto definitive
edition this one's a little complicated
grand theft auto 3 vice city and san
andreas have faced issues with certain
music tracks being removed from their
in-game radio stations due to music
licensing which isn't a new problem by
the way this has persisted with the
series ever since it came to pc like
metal gear solid 2 and 3 licensing is
contractual and only lasts for a certain
amount of time unless renewed and
sometimes that may not be the result is
that a list of songs you may love are
missing from gta's soundtrack and these
are problems that simply do not exist on
their physical versions if you own them
and have a means of playing them there's
still one other major issue with the gta
trilogy the definitive edition weeks
before its launch rockstar delisted the
original versions of the games from
digital storefronts making this new
iteration the only available version a
version mind you that launched with
uneven performance loads of bugs and was
swiftly removed from the rockstar's pc
launcher within a week of its release
due to its technical issues on november
19th 2021 rockstar issued an apology
announcing plans to patch the definitive
edition and are relisting the original
versions of the games
for the gaming medium it can sometimes
feel like its legacy is being written
and sand and more and more that feels
poignant especially with big companies
like rockstar just being able to disable
past versions of their games of the
current consoles xbox is leading the
charge and preserving its legacy content
thanks to a lofty catalog of backwards
compatible games
many of which are available digitally on
its storefront a lot of these games are
even getting enhancements like hdr
support and fps boosts in these cases it
feels like xbox is doing more than to
preserve them but actually give them
longevity on the other hand nintendo has
shown a more curated attempt at its
preservation with n64 super nintendo and
nintendo games through its online
membership but even still the whole
thing has been mishandled and consumers
aren't very happy about it
ports aren't entirely faithful some of
them are just straight up broken and
it's locked behind a membership plan so
even if you bought digital versions on
the wii or wii u you can't play these
versions on your switch lastly sony
doesn't appear to be actively doing
anything aside from small glimpses
through its ps now subscription service
sony swiftly backtracked its initial
decision to shut down the ps3 in vita
storefront but the psp is gone for good
but even still though the stores remain
open many payment options to support
them are disappearing then there's the
infamous case of the greatest horror
game that never was
pt the playable teaser for hideo
kojima's silent hills after the game's
cancellation kojima and konami parted
ways and the game was removed from psn
as of now there's no way to get it
unless you already had it downloaded for
your playstation 4 which is such a
commodity that there are people selling
their ps4s on ebay that have pt
installed on them
so as i move forward in what i view as
an inevitable all digital focused future
and witness some missteps of preserving
the past
i have in turn gone the absolute
opposite direction that i set out on a
couple years ago and honestly i still
really haven't quite come to terms
with how this all happened
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and what was a deliberate choice to get
rid of it and consolidate had somehow
turned into me pre-occurring of crt tv a
playstation 1 and a dreamcast
it's not entirely nostalgia either it's
rather experiencing these games the way
they were intended on the hardware they
were built for on the displays they were
meant to be seen on in fact i'm not only
collecting games i've already played but
instead trying to get ones i never have
before stuff that i missed out on like
shamnu and c-man and d2
worth every penny
now of course there's roms in emulation
and i'm well aware of what that does for
games in which the original publishers
have abandoned but for me and the
experience i've gone through it's not so
much about the digital preservation as
it is about the physical representation
of games from the past especially
considering that the physical side
is a fleeting one
i'm not entirely sure how i got here
but if i think if i if i'm able to
compare it to anything else it's
probably how i listen to music i listen
to a lot of music i'm an avid music
listener always trying to find something
new and i do that using digital
streaming services but once i find an
album that i love i usually go out of my
way to buy it on vinyl and then of
course i put on my record player and
listen to it with the speakers that i
have from start to finish with complete
immersion and in a way
it's kind of like me buying tekken 3
on the ps1 to play specifically on a crt
tv
and the whole experience is
kind of rather a meditative one
and i know that sounds a little
pretentious honestly but
it's in these practices
listening to music
in a certain way that demands my
attention playing games as they were
meant to be played kind of allows me to
value them a little more in a way that i
probably wouldn't get if i were to just
load up a rom there's nothing against
those who choose to play games that way
um this is just me and how my brain
works and how the drilling outside works
it's okay
you get the point
do i have any regrets no
not really sure i can't try before i buy
with games like return but if i'm being
completely honest if i really wanted it
i would have just bought it in this
journey however probably the most
interesting revelation was or is this
growing appreciation for legacy games
specifically getting them physically in
a way going digital has made me
appreciate the physicality of the past
one that i don't anticipate is coming
back while also comfortably accepting
what will most likely be
the digital future
so